you may be aware of the phrase jack of
all trades master of none my reference
to this next guest taysom hill master of
all trades
unbelievable offense defense special
teams we haven't seen you play defense
yet but we think you can run the ball
catch the ball whatever needs to be done
throw the ball 50 yards no big deal take
some milk so we've been looking forward
to this all week long future superstar
we want to get these guys before they
become too big to know who we are taysom
hill here in the flesh well i appreciate
you guys having me on and you know it's
interesting i feel like the story gets
better and better you know as the season
gets over and the stories get maybe a
little
no
you're a bullet crap but i'm gonna call
i'm throwing the challenge flag on you
right there yeah i mean mike mike hit it
on the day after you guys lost the
vikings and drew brees who we had
earlier today said the same thing that
mike said you were the best player on
the field in that game
and drew agreed and he just talked about
it like you know what is it like all of
a sudden being like in this notoriety
that you're getting out of nowhere well
look i'm not surprised that drew agreed
you know he's one of the best guys i've
been around and you know super humble
and when it's someone else he loves
talking about him but um look i would
say that i think so much of this has
been around coach payton and drew and
and i think
they're so good at putting guys in the
best position to be successful and you
know i've been the perfect example of
that and you know i'm grateful that they
created opportunities for me and right
and had a vision and said man this guy i
think can do this really well right and
they created opportunities
has he given you any inclination as to
what he's thinking about next coach we
tried no no no through
trying to get it out of drew today we
tried hard to get it out of the dream do
you have any idea what he's going to do
uh i i don't i don't i really don't um
and if i did i'm not sure that i'd be
blasting on this right now but
look i i think it's one of those things
where i wouldn't be surprised if he if
he retired i wouldn't be surprised if he
came back and and played again you know
i i can tell you i personally hope that
that he plays that he plays another year
and we had this conversation and and i
told him like man it
it would be so good for the nfl if you
came back and played again it'd be so
good for the saints it's just you know
but
you know that's me selfishly talking
yeah well the selfish take you should be
go ahead and retire i got this i'm ready
to take over to starting quarterback i
mean that that's what's strange about
this and i sense both of you guys really
want to be together even if it means
drew doesn't play as much as maybe he's
accustomed to because you're playing
more and even means you're not the guy
that drew's still the guy and you're
going to have to delay by at least a
year your chance to become a starting
quarterback in everything you can be as
a quarterback sure look
honestly he has been so good for my
career like i didn't know what i didn't
know before i got to the nfl yeah i hear
you and i started working with drew and
i saw the way that he prep for games and
my eyes i was like you know during the
headlights i i didn't realize what it
took to play at this level and so you
know having the opportunity to learn
from him be with him has been the best
thing for me he's been you know he's
really become like a big brother to me
he's one of my best friends
and you know as as you mentioned i i
certainly hope that that he comes back
in place yeah well i mean he said he's
he's totally open if he does come back
to play too like if if you've got to
play quarterback 30 snaps he's down for
it he doesn't care so just to let you
know
if i'm back and taysom's alongside me
call the plays that put us in the best
position to win if that means taysom is
taking 30 snaps a game so be it i'm all
for that that's what we said
he's coming back i just i just feel like
in our interview he's coming back i
really do but i want to ask you about
you here because like i'm amazed by you
i really am i always knew you were this
like physical freak athlete i had heard
from some coach friends about like what
you looked like when you first got to
new orleans but i'm so impressed with
your throwing and your like
quarterbacking year by year like
pre-season this year i turn on the film
and i'm like whoa
taysom hill is like got it down like who
have you worked with what have you done
to like polish yourself that way yeah
well i think i i look back at my my
college career and unfortunately i had
so many injuries that i wasn't able to
really focus on the quarterback position
the way that it needs to be because i
was rehabbing injury every year
and being in the nfl i haven't had to
deal with the injuries and i got to work
with drew and he brings in tom house he
brings in all these guys and man i'm
telling you drew just was like ah here
you go
here's everything that's made me great
for so long and so i've just tried to be
a sponge yeah and so to answer your
question i really adopted all of his
workout habits his workout routine i
started working with tom house and um i
really had time to allocate to the
position yeah now when you're starting
quarterback not if but when you're
starting quarterback in the nfl they're
probably not going to want you to be on
the punt team and trying to block punts
and running the ball like the bull in
the china shop like are you going to be
trying to still volunteer to get out
there and do these special teams or you
look you accept as a starting
quarterback there's a certain level of
protection you need to
put yourself in yeah i i think the
special team stuff will be you know put
away
yeah um we'll we'll go away yeah gunner
anymore no i i think you know to answer
your question about running around like
a bowling a china shop i think
that's always been something i've
challenged with throughout my entire
career well where
man if it's third down if it's you know
on the goal line and you're trying to
score like whatever i'm i'm so
competitive and i want to
create opportunities for our team to win
or get keep a drive going and and so
forth and um
so that is something that i've struggled
with you know of protecting myself and
getting down and doing that but i'll
tell you you know i i think our
quarterback coach kind of senses that
and so he's always putting plugs in like
ah we'll be watching film he's like ah
don't take that hit don't take that hit
yeah i'm not directly talking about me
but
what it takes to play this this position
yeah right um i i'm like you're you're
you're built out of granite all right
like what do we do workout wise like i'm
always interested you know mike always
hears me talking about guys bodies and
legs and butt and everything like you
got it all and i've heard about some of
your your weight like are you still
lifting heavy are you do like squat
heavy and power clean heavy still uh
yeah i do i do um
during the season i will say it's the
goal for me is hey let's maintain
everything that i that i accomplished
and i gained in the offseason right but
when i get to my off-season workouts
like i'm i'm lifting a lot of weight
yeah i'm working out really hard i want
some freaking numbers like what are we
doing like squatting wise i mean you're
not doing like one rep stuff are you
still no no i was the last time i did
that i was like i hit up in the 600s for
squatting one rep max squad
um but like all right so how heavy we
get in like this off season what will
you do like i mean i'll rep out 500
pounds you will yeah like three five of
them yeah
damn man i'll do power look i i think
you know as i like do my research on
working out and what it takes and trying
to be fast it's it's all about how much
force can you put in my ground right
right and so
as i've done research and and i know
just as well as you guys you hear
numbers like that and you're like oh
you're crazy what are you doing because
longevity no i was like that i i was
like you and i i love your pounds but my
mac i was like 350 i was like that but i
would on a monday after a game i would
put like 350 on my back and squat like
box squats five of them yeah it's it
it's great and look i i haven't i don't
get sore after i like i don't have any
chronic issues that way um and to me it
makes me feel strong powerful i feel
like i can run fast because i can
generate force right
that's that's really important yeah one
of the byproducts of being a great
player you get some partnerships you get
some sponsorships as chris says you
can't hide money what do you got going
on with what you got going on with tonal
yeah tono is a young company that i'm
really excited about um you know i just
had one installed in my place
and it really is
a complete gym it's one of these things
that you can mount on your wall
but it has a weight system inside of it
but it doesn't take up all the space in
the room so
if i can't get to a gym or i can't get
into to do a lift it's got a personal
trainer artificial intelligence inside
the machine it's it's pretty incredible
right that's pretty good and you can
just would you say you could put it like
on your wall i mean just mounts on your
wall yeah it's super sleek um it's it's
a it's a really nice product personal
trainer inside the system that will walk
you through different workouts wow
that's that's cutting edge crap right
there i mean
it's crap it's cutting edge awesome
stuff i just mean you know i'm an idiot
from jersey sorry yes and yes
but hey it's it's great to finally meet
you to talk to you we we are looking
forward to great things from taysom hill
presumably with the saints we didn't get
into restricted freedom yeah
we hope it's with the saints and we hope
to see you on the field doing the things
you were doing in that wild card game
because it was special yeah thank you
very much all right there you go
we'll be back with more from miami
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports